Alicia is with us in Texas hi Alicia how
are you I must have missed the button
let me try it again there it is hey
Alicia how are you
am I here now there you are now how can
I help
well my mom died in May I'm sure and
thank you there are my father passed
away about nine years ago and he left
money to her and now she has left money
to me and my three siblings in addition
to her death I'm the executor of her
estate I have also just been granted
guardianship by the state of my 30 year
old brother and both his person and his
estate the money that my mother has left
him and I'm going through a divorce Wow
what are you oh yeah is your brother
disabled he has been found incapacitated
due to addiction issues and mental
health issues
Wow how challenging I'm so sorry
thank you how old is he
30 okay does he work now or is he I've
never had a job okay okay and so how
much was the inheritance I'm so far in
beneficiary payments we need receives
about $300,000 there'll be more after I
settle her estate to the terminal or
what
oh we're not exactly sure but we'll
probably another 50 to each of us okay
sure you don't have 350 you don't have
$350,000 in his name that your to manage
for his good okay meanwhile you've got
it we've already put two hundred
thousand dollars in safekeeping so I
only have access to a hundred thousand
but that's going toward rehab and the
thing is like that right now
okay so safekeeping what does that mean
since I don't have to be bonded by the
court or the amount of money that I can
manage and so since we don't want I
don't you know nobody wants me to go buy
a Ferrari I don't want a Ferrari but you
know they put it under seal basically
with the bank so that nobody can touch
that money without a court order that we
are filing motions to be able to invest
that money yeah I would think yeah if
you if you you know so your mother
trusted you to manage it for the good of
your brother but the court didn't no no
no she had said that if he if she passed
before he was 13 then a trust would be
set up for the proceeds of her a stage
but beneficiary payments are outside of
the estate so the courts are now I am
now his guardian as of two or three
weeks ago and I'm only I'm only want
access to a portion of it for now
the rest of it is just set aside you
know I just had wanted to invested for
his good you know the court order
sticking it in a bank and calling it
safe doesn't make sense to me oh that's
not what's happening at all okay you
said safekeeping and it was in a bank I
didn't know it yeah it's it's an item I
didn't know these legal terms either
okay it's the safekeeping orders that I
only have access to a certain portion of
it and the rest of it is going to be
invested by direction later on / Tyler
its invested per your direction correct
okay it will be alright anyway so how
can I help
well you know I I think I've got him
pretty much that I learned diversify
them in four ways and I'm going to take
[ __ ] out you know as I need them as he
spent as I spend money for his care and
health concerns and then there's me I'm
going through a divorce my husband has
left the home I have two children and I
have money now too and I want to make
good decisions with it and I can't even
breathe at this point talking on my own
with all that's gone on
okay so do you have a career I did right
now I do not I two years ago I closed
down my business because I had four
surgeries that one problem after another
how old or 30 40 what are you gonna do
with your life I don't know yet right
now I'm gonna get through this next six
months okay you need to have a plan
because 33 and $50,000 is gonna be gone
in about 20 seconds if you don't have a
plan oh I have better plans than that
okay all right because if you if we can
create to the extent we can you can
create an income and child support to
take care of your children
yeah to the extent that there's enough
money to do that you don't have to touch
this 350 that's you know then then then
you can invest it and let it grow and
you know use it for some wise things to
the extent you have to use it to live on
it's gonna burn fairly quickly if it
were invested at 10% it would create
thirty five thousand dollars a year
right exactly and that's still not
probably enough to live on the way
you're used to living so that you know
it's your process so in the midst of you
being overwhelmed and having an
incredible pile of things to emotionally
walk through and deal with bless your
heart I mean you really got your plate
folk you know in the midst of all of
that and the midst all of that you got
to get a cup of coffee in an open Bible
sit on the back patio and go okay God
what do you want me to do ten years from
now I'd like to kind of start walking
towards the light
mm-hmm exactly so I mean my I plan
because I don't have a current job I
plan to pay off my house early about 95
okay all right that's not bad right
about worth 240 okay and then you got to
free it and then you got to create an
income to live on I do and I will know
I'll probably start another business
well I mean you got to allocate that
money out but that the point is the
thing that kills people is not distress
it's the not knowing that'll drive you
bonkers ambivalence is harder than
challenges and so that's what I'm trying
to walk with you through here in our
discussion is if you'll get some things
where you know what to do what your next
three steps are on these different
issues whether it's the divorce the
grieving of your mom's passing the
dealing with your brother's situation
the dealing with your career what are
your next three steps what are your next
four steps and begin to take them your
stress starts to melt away but even if
it's hard it's easier because you know
you got to know